the so-called great savior of democracy
is back fresh off his Caribbean vacation
where he got sunburned into Oblivion
President Biden was out in Valley Forge
to kick off his first major campaign
speech of the year but it looks like the
big guy is all out of Big Ideas instead
of talking about his policies or how
he'll make your lives better Biden
bashed Maga supporters and January 6th
the president repeatedly mentioned
George Washington while fashioning
himself as a Defender against
dictatorship Donald Trump's campaign is
about him not America not you Donald
Trump's campaign is obsessed with the
past not the future he's willing to
sacrifice our democracy put himself in
power and yet Trump and his mag of
supporters not only Embrace political
violence but they laugh about it so hear
me clearly I'll say what Donald Trump
won't political violence is never ever
acceptable in the United States
political system never never never it
has no place in a democracy this is like
something out of a fairy tale bad fairy
tale he went on to
say he'd be a dictator on day
one Biden also claiming that you better
vote for him or it's the end of
democracy I make this sacred pledge to
you the defense protection and
preservation of American democracy will
remain as it has been the central cause
of my presidency democracy is on the
ballot your freedom is on the ballot we
hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men and women are
created equal and I promise you I will
not let Donald Trump with the mag of
Republicans Force us to walk away and
while Joe jins up fear that your next
door neighbor could be a Maga extremist
the media just got busted for
perpetuating an extremism hoax you may
remember how Democrats and the liberal
press breathlessly hyped The Narrative
that dangerous right-wing radicals had
infiltrated our American Military well
Joe Biden's own Department of Defense
looked into the allegations and they
found no evidence that the US military
is packed with violent extremist
according to the report there were few
more than 100 substantiated cases per
year of extremist activities by members
of the military in recent
years all right Jesse um I'll start with
you how Joe Biden ran and he was going
to unite the country how does pitting 73
million Americans against the rest of
America unite the
country well by the way what are you
doing for January 6 you want to come
over to my house we're having a little
stop the steel watch party and dress
Jesse Jr up in animal skins play a
little game we like to call find the DNC
pipe
bomb year after year we have not found
it pop quiz Jessica which president
skipped the 911 ceremony and did the
January 6 ceremony 3 two one that would
be Jo
Biden this guy can't save democracy when
he's trying to rip his opponent off of
the ballot slap him with
gags and have him
arrested judge he ran his first campaign
on Charlottesville the second campaign
is now on January 6th he actually thinks
Donald Trump wants to be a dictator so
the first campaign he ran on was a hoax
the second one this is now a joke you
can't actually be from the party that
literally started a racist Insurrection
and accused the other party of the same
thing that's like Bill Clinton saying
it's disqualifying for someone to sleep
with an intern and run for office I am
so tired of Joe Biden running on January
6 if I were Donald Trump i r on July 4th
no one is more patriotic than Donald
Trump I remember back in like the late
80s he was talking about the Japanese
ripping us off while Joe Biden was
blocking a black man from the court and
Joe Biden's letting China pillage this
country Donald Trump launched a trade
war against them Donald Trump secured
the Border Joe Biden's letting 5 million
Mystery Men just wander in what kind of
patriotic person does that Donald Trump
spent his whole life building skycrapers
creating jobs developing beautiful
tracks of land Joe Biden's sitting on
his ker backs slapping and glad handing
his whole life done nothing he's done
nothing and the racism thing that has to
stop Jessica okay Donald Trump dated
black
women has Joe Biden ever dated a black
woman
Donald Trump was ping around with Don
King when your guy was ping around with
segregationists okay Joe bid has been no
no no I'm not finished all right there's
a Fox News Alert oh fine I'll I'll
finish after the alert all right we have
a Fox News Alert the United States
Supreme Court has agreed to hear the
appeal of former president Trump's
Colorado ballot
disqualification oral arguments will be
held Thursday February 8th
all right Sandra let's talk about that
uh Colorado the justices all Democrats
took Joe Biden off uh took Donald Trump
I'm sorry off the ballot main Secretary
of State a Democrat takes him off the
ballot how is it that you've got the
candidate for President Joe Biden saying
he's saving democracy when his party is
taking the number one at this point
sought after candidate not just in the
Republican party but in terms of the
polls Donald Trump off the bow and what
we have seen in the polls is this just
only firing up his base even more uh so
the more they go after him the more they
try to take him off the ballot message
is this fires up the base improves his
status in the polls and it will benefit
him in this election year I think
there's a lot to take in here and tying
it into our overall discussion with what
we heard from President Biden a short
time ago I think there's a couple ways
to look at that there was a very firm
message that was delivered by the
president there uh agree with it
disagree with it um that was a president
that is fired up and ready to run
against that man uh the former president
Donald Trump as far as the content is
concerned tie this into this as well
what you just said judge he said
President Biden today democracy is on
the ballot uh freedom is on the ballot
Jonathan Turley came in on the air right
after that speech concluded and he said
we would be remiss not to say that this
has been one of the most anti-free
speech presidencies of our lifetime um
of you know potentially in our history
of the country Nikki Haley was on our
air right before Biden took to that
Podium she used it as a campaign message
right she said watch you're gonna see
President Biden tee off against Donald
Trump in his first campaign speech do
you put Donald Trump up there as your
nominee this is what you're gonna see
this Trump Biden fight that's going to
continue in that message Biden said
Donald Trump's campaign is obsessed with
the past not the future that is irony
considering President Biden stood up
there and did not tout what he has done
right he could not look back at the past
of what he his performance in office
Jess guy saw the look um nice to see you
guys are getting along here but how can
you tout $3 a gallon gasoline right now
right an economy where consumer prices
are up 17% go to the grocery store right
now that's why he's not pulling well in
the economy and security going back to
the Border people don't feel safe in
their neighborhoods right now so this is
all on the ballot all right Jessica you
want to respond to that sure I would
love to um so today's speech was not
about anything but January 6th and
saving democracy you can give a speech
tomorrow about the economy and there
have been commentators all over every
major Channel including our own talking
about how good today's job report
numbers were 216 uh th000 jobs at it
3.7% unemployment 4.1% wage growth one
of the most interesting things it's the
lowest black unemployment rate that
we've ever had in history he has a lot
to talk about and he will that but today
was about saving democracy and the
contrast between Joe Biden who yes
whether he is invigorated from having
some time off which he rightly deserved
um or maybe this is just how campaign
mode is going to be and I hope that is
true he's talking about this and Donald
Trump is posting memes about how quote
God made Trump and over 40 posts going
after egene Carol a woman he was found
to have sexually assaulted and defamed
the reason that Joe Biden is talking
about January 6th and former president
Trump living in the past is because he
has not moved on from the big lie to the
fact that we just saw in the Detroit
news last night this story came out that
the Trump campaign directly coordinated
the filing of a certificate signed by 16
Michigan Republicans that falsely
claimed that he won the state Jack Smith
will obviously get his day in court to
bring the case about January 6 sixth
election interference we will see what
happens in fton County in Georgia but
this man continues to lie to the entire
world about what happened in the
election and he did F what happened on
January 6th all of his friends and
family and closest advisers were texting
him begging him to stop doing it and
what did he do he said Mike Pence didn't
do what he was supposed to to a crowd
and I guess you call them Taurus some
people carrying the Confederate flag
there was a noose on the Pres on the
premises of of January 6th and cops were
beaten Windows smashed people showed up
with zip ties this was not a friendly
Affair so this is the contrast and this
is why Joe Biden won by 7 million votes
because you have a person who wants to
subvert democracy and a person who
accepts Democratic results and the
Colorado case was brought by Republicans
it also went through a 5-day bench trial
it should go to the Supreme Court and I
imagine that they will rule that his
name should be on the ballot but it has
nothing to do with Democratic to take
your opponent's name off the ballot Joe
Biden has nothing to do with it the same
way nothing to do
with laptop all right Greg I want you to
listen to this sound the media pedal
better than this the media pedal Lloyd
Austin's claims of extremism in the
military which we now know is false take
a listen these extreme views aren't new
uh they have existed Within in the
military for a while is Austin the right
person to handle rooting out extremism
for the from the
military you don't you know he
absolutely is he does have a unique
understanding of the challenge that we
challenges that we Face here I think
this is a major problem this is
something that the military that
Congress uh that everyone in positions
of power need to be looking at and
investigating and taking very
seriously well it's this this is all
part of the same Strate y absent of
policy and ideas all they do is cling to
January 6 which believe it or not was
not an Insurrection it's probably the
only coup in history that didn't have
any arms and the person that died was an
unarmed protester named Ashley babbit
who was a veteran so let's talk about
this military extremism hoax right the
media embraced this I'm going to compare
this to Epstein which every time we talk
about Epstein we say oh these people are
innocent until proven guilty we didn't
say that about the military MSNBC quote
extremism in the military is a serious
national security threat where's the
data on that you bozos CNN the military
has long had an extremist problem what
will it do now to finally solve it where
was your evidence on that you douchebags
NPR the military confronts extremism one
conversation on a time you guys are
asses okay we've had millions of people
risk their lives defending this country
and you have this old old decrepit Crone
falsely smearing these Patriots with
extremism not because they knew it to be
true but in order to create fear to
drive voters to their side and then the
truth comes out they release this report
Before Christmas right they knew that
the media would let it slide because
they were complicit in this lie so they
knew it would slide we're the only
people covering this but if they had
found racism in this this would be on
the cover of every news site it would be
linked to Fox News it would be linked to
Donald Trump they would call our
military hopelessly racist we would need
more CRT more
ESG has Joe ever apologized to the
Border agents which he did the same
thing to he ran with a smear targeted a
private citizen and did and then would
have found out to be false which we all
knew it was false he said nothing has he
apologized to the military for this for
creating and fomenting a hoax against
American citizens that was deliberate it
wasn't something that got out of hand
like a rally this was planned they went
after these people and now think about
the Epstein thing okay every time you
hear the Epstein story right they
preface it with a legal Preamble we have
no evidence of wrongdoing hey douchebags
that didn't stop you from going for
calling people white supremacists from
pushing the P tape from from going after
the Border agents and now it's Epstein's
Pals innocent till proven guilty but
military border agents they're guilty
from the get-go Biden should hold a
press conference and announce these
findings but he won't he's a tool upon
Pawn a callous old coot who exploits
division to preserve
power Jesse you're supposed to say and
that's what I have to say about that
that's I'll be talking about this night
on my show at 10 p.m. I just want to add
to do you want me to add to the news so
you can no don't add to the news we
don't need any
more so the Supreme Court is not going
to help Joe Biden out this time they he
Joe Biden had so much help the last time
he ran he had a once in a hundred-year
virus come in the FBI descended on
Minneapolis went to the coroner's office
you know those tapes were suppressed and
then he gets helped from the feds and
the agency with the laptop and fizer
like happens to discover the vaccine and
works like the day after the election
come on Joe doesn't have any of that
this time the country's wide-eyed about
what to expect when it comes to rigging
and it's not going to go the same way
according to Alina habba uh the Supreme
Court is in Donald Trump's pocket she
was on TV last night talking about how
Brett Cav is going to do the right thing
because you know how he got on the court
well I don't think it's hard to do the
right thing it's going to be nothing
we'll get a Little Help from the uh no
that that my understanding of what said
was she's concerned that you know people
may think that because there were
appointments by Donald Trump that the
Supreme Court will go that way she
doesn't believe that to be the case
concerned this is this Administration
the Biden Administration has done more
to destroy Free Speech the ability of
the press to uh provide information to
us and to win the election for Joe Biden
it was orwellian the way they handled it
and that's why he won because had people
known about that laptop and all of the
president when the laptop was censored
for 24 hours also there was nothing you
could do about it oh so oh so was Donald
Trump's fault that the uh folks who were
friends with Obama and Biden came out
and said that's Russian disinformation
suppress the laptop okay so no I don't
think so that was B and Anthony blinkin
himself said that he's the one who
contacted people to get together to say
that it was disinformation when
something happens during your
Administration oh really oh really yes
that's what I hear every day from you
guys on Joe Biden's watch on Donald
Trump's watch Hunter Biden's laptop
story was censored for a mere 24 hours
off Twitter and people were still until
the election it was 24 hours judge
people still had you come on Jessica who
are you kidding that laptop story was
not allowed to be discussed on social
media only the New York Post reported it
you're wrong but no I'm not wrong and
we are monitoring the breaking news hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else